- Onions make you cry
but this onion's about to make you laugh.
Pe woop!
Mortician always keeps
hammer at table side
just in case one comes back to life.
Has that ever happened?
Like I'm sure there's
some kind of crazy story
and what are you gonna do?
Murder them?
(laughs)
Shouldn't you give them assistance?
Dr. Sholl's introduces new amputation kit
for dry cracked feet.
Touting the product's
ability to not only treat,
but also prevent and remove the condition.
I added the remove.
Honestly, my left foot.
I don't know what it is.
I thought it was fungal,
it's not really fungal.
I thought it was like
some kind of eczema thing.
It could be, it could be psoriasis.
I got a dry cracked feet on my foot.
Patients impressed by
how big baby has gotten
after just 16 months of CrossFit.
Whoa, that's a Diesel baby!
We covered this on strangest
addictions with the family,
like they work out a lot.
You know, some of it is really healthy,
but sometimes it could
be dangerous depending
on the type of exercise
and the age of the child.
So you gotta be really careful
and ask your doctor for
guidance in this situation.
Shortage of supplies forces
surgeon to wear boxing gloves
for the operation.
Yes!
This is gonna be me in the office one day.
Boxing gloves would be terrible
for the operating room.
New study finds most
premature births occur
after fetus smells
something delicious outside.
Such a funny image.
I don't think that's why
premature births happen
but we could put together
a study to find out.
Imagine like you cook a really good pie
and the baby's like, "Oh,
I gotta come out now"
(beep)
New Fisher Price, Doctor Kit
just prescription pad and
bottles of (chuckles).
This Fisher Price kit is severely lacking.
We also prescribe other
opioids besides fentanyl.
That was a joke.
Humanitarian organization
"Doctors without dimensions"
phases into war-torn nonlinear universe.
I feel like this is headlined
by Elon Musk himself.
How do you treat an alien
when you don't even know
what's inside of them?
Surgeon totally blanks on
what he cut open patient
(chuckles) for.
That's like surgeon says "Oops"
in an operating room is the
last thing you want to hear.
Now, why the hell did I
make this giant slit again?
Said Mitchell of the six
long transverse incision
he made across his subject's abdomen.
God, I hope this doesn't happen.
The onion's guide to HIPAA.
You know what's funny?
I've been seeing a lot of these TikToks
of people just yelling HIPAA.
- You cannot record me.
That is against my HIPAA law.
- You're in a hardware store.
HIPAA doesn't apply here.
What is HIPAA?
The reason you have to sign
up for some new website ending
in "Portal."
Every time you go to a
different urgent care.
Fact.
What does it stand for?
Health, information, portability
and accountability act.
(glass crashes)
- [Dan] Is it health insurance or.
- [Sam] I think it's health insurance.
(laughs)
(beep)
- [Doctor] Centers for
disease control let's smallpox
and rinderpest viruses out
for daily hours (chuckles)
exercise.
Oh my God, that sounds frightening.
Someone needs to tell me
what a rinderpest virus is.
And if you know I'm gonna be impressed.
Jimmy Carter already back to
Elite Sumo Wrestling circuit,
after recovering from
hip surgery (chuckles).
What is this image?
I wanna learn more about Sumo Wrestling.
Not because of Jimmy Carter, but because,
it has a rich history.
Hospital adds $20,000 scan
that informs patient
whether they have feet.
Okay, this pokes at fun
at the fact that a lot
of people order tests,
without any real purpose.
You basically are just confirming
that the patient in fact has bones.
If you just felt the patient's anatomy
and watched them walk
and assess their gate
you would know the
answer to that question.
By the way, if you didn't
know I'm going on tour
Boston, Philly, Red
Bank New Jersey, and DC.
Link down below.
Improv, comedy, games,
audience participation.
You're gonna have a blast.
I guarantee, get your tickets now.
They're selling out quickly.
All right, let's get back to it.
Breakthrough procedure allows
surgeons to transplant pig rib
directly into human mouth.
That's funny, because you
can have the surgeon make
like a really nice cuts in it.
That would be pretty tasty.
Yum.
Exercising woman really
starting to feel the burn
of lifelong injury developing.
"Oh yeah, I'm definitely
starting to feel some results
from my repeated misuse of the treadmill
and poor running techniques."
Nothing funny about this,
because you cannot imagine
how often this happens.
Even one of my closest
friends the other day,
pulled his psoas muscle really badly.
Because he decided that it was cool to run
at seven miles per hour on the treadmill,
on like a six incline,
for like five miles.
That's not a smart play.
At least do intervals where
the treadmill goes up,
goes down.
Unless you training for
something very specific
and you're gradually building up there.
The body's not ready to
handle that kind of load.
It's not bio mechanically friendly.
It will cause pain.
Man concerned that doctor
wants to discuss test results
at morgue rather
(chuckles) over the phone.
Although he wasn't an
expert, he had a bad feeling
about the physician's insistence
on going over his angiogram
face to face, while he was lying down
on the stainless steel table in a facility
full of dead bodies.
If your doctor calls and asks
you to have a conversation
face to face at the morgue.
That should raise red flags.
Effective billboard has
driver suddenly craving
to visit the hospital.
Where first class care,
always comes first.
I'm not gonna lie, the
billboards that some hospitals,
even ones that I've worked at before.
Are freaking weird.
I get what they're doing,
they're trying to encourage
patients to come in
and get care and they're competing
with other healthcare
systems and all of that.
I hope what happens is
patients are alerted
to the fact that they
have a facility near them,
where they can get care,
in case of necessity.
Connor McGregor undergoes
three hours of surgery
to repair fractured ego.
Oh my God!
That last injury was the
definition of a fractured ego.
You could see, by the way,
he acted out in the octagon
after the fight.
Poor poor poor class.
Poor sportsmanship in my eyes.
Neurosurgeon holds
spinal cord between teeth
to free up hands while
performing delicate incision.
That's the worst Photoshop job
I think I've ever seen in my life.
I'm gonna go ahead
and accurately debunk
why this is not good.
A, if you've removed the
patient's entire spine,
probably not compatible with living
unless it's a very unique situation.
If you're gonna put the spine back,
putting it in your mouth,
which is potentially the dirtiest,
meaning most bacteria rich
filled area of your body.
You probably don't wanna
put back into the patient.
New Hanes shapewear compresses woman
into flattering trapezoid.
I don't understand.
Is this like a play on spanx?
Eight and a half month old fetus
could really get used to this.
"Man, I gotta tell you, this is the life",
said the 37-week fetus.
"I'm a snug as a bug in a rug here,
but I've still got enough room
to turn a full 180 degrees.
Plus there's this super fun umbilical cord
I can play with or wear as a necklace."
Don't wear as a necklace.
It's a big problem, baby.
Or fetus.
Gwyneth Paltrow.
Uh-oh, the goop is coming.
Gwyneth Paltrow introduced
a new diamond-encrusted
trepanation drill and drainage
bucket on her website?
"With just a few cranks,
this elegant, stainless
steel drill can pierce
through the thickest parts of
your cranial bone in seconds.
Leading to instantly relief
from evil demons, ghosts,
and spirits possessing the soul",
under description on Goop.com.
They actually use drills like this
in like the neural ICU or a neurosurgery.
But why Gweneth Paltrow has
anything to do with this,
is just like Satanic to me.
Woman puts off going
to doctor until disease
is bad enough to believe her.
"I'd love to get an appointment
soon, but it's just easier
if I show up sick enough to force his hand
to actually give me the
correct medical care."
I wanna laugh, but it's
more sad than anything.
Doctors misunderstand women.
And because they misunderstand women
they end up not believing women.
I think it's a issue of training
and the lack of experience
to working with a diverse
patient population.
And you need to be able to be ready for it
and adjust and be able to communicate
with all different types of patients.
Doctors recommend getting
eight centuries of cryosleep.
This could be a headline from the future
or it could be a headline
for these biohackers.
And boy, have these biohackers
gotten on my nerves.
"Make sure to forgo caffeine
and silence your phone
before replacing your blood
with medical-grade antifreeze."
There are some good advice
here, like forgo caffeine,
good advice.
Getting your phone out of the room.
Good advice.
And the number one sleep thing,
that I tell people all the time.
No more than 15-20 minutes of
trying to fall asleep in bed.
Otherwise, get out of the bed.
Go try and fall asleep on the couch.
Read a book, because the
more you struggle in bed,
the more you associate all
those negative feelings
and that anxiety with the bed.
As opposed to getting tired elsewhere
and wanting and craving your bed.
So the moment you touch,
you can fall asleep
into a sound full
zzz.
CDC unveils list of Twitter
accounts you can follow
to piece together vaccine information.
"Following these reporters,
medical researchers
and politically engaged musicians
will provide the updates necessary
to cobble together some sense
of what exactly is going on
with our vaccine rollout."
This is probably the most
accurate onion article
we're gonna see, because I feel like,
the CDC is an amazing organization.
Rich with brilliant individuals,
but somehow they fail to
consider the importance
of a proper communications department.
When certain decisions are made
give the reasoning for why
those decisions are made.
If they change, explain
the reasons for the change.
And when you ask people
to do their own research
it's gonna lead them to go on to Facebook
and see all these crazy things
that maybe some of their
friends are posting.
Do you know what detox
teas do to your health?
Click here to find out.
As always stay happy and healthy.
Really curious what you
think about this video?
Because in it, I tell the honest truth.
Not just the truth, the honest truth.
(upbeat latino music)